d'anciens présidents est entrée dans les
livres d'histoire le premier condamné à
une peine de prison ferme pour
corruption
nicolas sarkozy et son avocat de longue
date thierry herzog coupable d'avoir
tenté d'obtenir des informations
confidentielles auprès d'un magistrat
en échange ce jus s'était vu promettre
l'influencent de nicolas sarkozy pour
l'aider à obtenir un prestigieux poste à
monaco
aux yeux du tribunal il s'agit d'un
pacte de corruption minant la confiance
du public dans la justice selon cet
avocat
le verdict est de nature à corriger le
tir la décision elle-même allez allez
rassurante pour le justiciable
parce que le justiciable que vous soyez
président avocat
magistrat le
normalement la loi est la même pour tout
le monde il n'y a pas de réseau et deux
poids deux mesures les preuves sont
tirés des coûte téléphoniques mises en
place dans une autre affaire touchant
l'ancien président un possible
financement libyen de sa campagne
électorale
nicolas sarkozy est resté de marbre
lorsque la sentence a été prononcée
trois années de prison dont une à
curgies autoparodie qu'il a quitté le
tribunal sans faire de commentaire son
avocate par l'incompréhension et
d'indignation devant une décision qui
fera l'objet d'un appel
il est déterminé c'est une étape et il
est déjà passé à l'étape suivante c'est
ce qui le caractérise et puis ce que je
dois dire aussi c'est que nicolas
sarkozy est présumé innocent il le sait
et il sait il sait que cette innocence
triomphera jours attendant cet appel le
nom de nicolas sarkozy demeure associé à
ceux d'autres politiciens français
condamné par la justice comme jacques
chirac pour détournement de fonds
publics
il ya des partisans de nicolas sarkozy
voit cette décision comme le résultat
d'un acharnement mené par des procureurs
financiers la seule chose qui compte
c'est que toute la lumière soit faite
sur l'action et sur les méthodes
d'action du parc national financier qui
est d'ailleurs très contesté y compris
par la magistrature
l'ancien président sarkozy il n'en a pas
terminé avec la justice dans deux
semaines environ il doit revenir dans ce
même tribunal
cette fois pour faire face à des
accusations d'avoir dépassé les limites
de dépenses lors de la campagne
présidentielle de 2012 une campagne qui
l'a perdu ici il ya un argument baron
radio-canada paris